kitty monterrey nicaragüense y dirigente
política se vio obligada a exiliarse en
costa rica luego que se le despojara de
su nacionalidad y que su partido fuera
eliminado de la contienda electoral en
nicaragua por parte del gobierno del
presidente daniel ortega el gobernante
del frente sandinista maneja todos los
poderes del estado y no tendrá
competencia en las urnas hay una boleta
con varios partidos pero todos los
partidos que aparecen en esa boleta
electoral son simplemente aliados del
frente sandinista eliseo núñez también
refugiado trabajaba con uno de los siete
aspirantes presidenciales opositores
detenidos en nicaragua cuyo antes de que
su destino fuera una cárcel nicaragüense
yo sigo siendo acosado por el régimen
aún estando aquí la policía llega a mi
casa periódicamente la rodea
ortega es es una persona intolerante y
básicamente él cree que el poder y
nicaragua le pertenece periodistas
nicaragüenses en el exilio señalan que
la cobertura de las elecciones será de
sumo riesgo para porteros independientes
que siguen en el país todavía existe
persecución hay más medios de
comunicación que han sido cerrados más
periodistas que están saliendo al exilio
las condiciones hay un estado policial
donde las personas no pueden expresarse
los que están todavía en nicaragua lo
hacen con muy bajo perfil no firman sus
notas informativas
no salen con libertad pues con un
teléfono voy a transmitir a x el lugar
en nicaragua porque te puede caer la
policía decenas de miles de
nicaragüenses llegaron a costa rica tras
el estallido de la crisis nicaragüense
en 2018 muchos anhelan retornar pero
aseguran que no pueden hacerlo a menos
que haya un cambio de gobierno una
posibilidad que parece alejarse tras que
el cierre de la vía electoral